>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Mark Walker: My
name is Mark Walker.
My stage name is Professor Horn.
And I've been performing Punch
and Judy now for about 25 years.
>> Michelle Stefano: For those
who aren't really familiar
with what Punch and
Judy shows are,
would you mind giving
us a little overview?
>> Mark Walker: Yes, it's
a very funny puppet show,
and I think it's one of the
things that attracts me to it.
It's -- they say
that authentic Punch
and Judy shows have several
elements to it, one of which is
that it would have use of
a slapstick in the show.
It would also -- the performer
would also use a swazzle.
That's S-W-A-Z-Z-L-E.
And it's a little device.
It's made of metal and tape.
And you balance it on your
tongue, and it's almost
like a reed instrument.
So, when you -- it
has to be wet.
And as you speak, the words
come through there, and it's --
that's how Mr. Punch talks.
But they say if it doesn't
have that, technically,
it's not considered a
Punch and Judy show.
There are some basic
characters to the show.
Of course, there's Punch, Judy,
the baby, the police officer,
and there are other characters
such as Joey the Clown,
a crocodile, and
sausages, and so forth.
But no two Punch and
Judy shows are alike.
There are some similarities
in that when Punch comes up
and meets Judy, they have
-- they bring out the baby.
There's some sort of
interaction between them.
Something usually happens to the
baby, and then there's a call
for the police officer.
And then from there, it
just goes in a million
and one different directions.
It's left up to the performer
to take it from there.
And not all shows
actually have a crocodile.
It can. Most shows do.
But I've seen some shows
end with the devil.
So, it's -- and again,
a lot of variety in it.
And that's what makes
it kind of fun, too.
[Inaudible], so.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
Punch and Judy shows,
the roots go back
many centuries.
>> Mark Walker: Yes.
Well, it was first seen in
England in -- on May 9th, 1662.
There was a man named
Samuel Pepys.
He was a journalist.
He kept a diary.
And he noted that there was
this very funny puppet show.
And at the time, it was
actually marionettes, and it --
it just took a long
time, hundreds of years,
for the show to evolve.
And of course, there
was no Judy in the show.
She came about later, as did
some of the other characters.
The devil, and so forth.
But the devil and
Judy, her name was Jo,
were the earlier
puppets in the program.
And as time went on, again, it
took hundreds of years to evolve
from marionettes
to glove puppets,
and for these characters to
be introduced into the show.
And like -- even like
the -- there's like --
like you have the police
officer, but back then --
if you ever saw the movie,
Oliver, there's a character
in there who's known
as the Beetle.
And he was sort of like -- I
guess it would be their version
of a police officer back then.
So, they would introduce
this Beetle character
and they would call
for the Beetle.
He would come up, and again,
there were interactions.
But as that character
became out of fashion,
then they put the
police officer in.
So, the show was always
moving and evolving.
And there's always novelty
scenes in the show, too.
I was telling somebody
where it was --
I've seen some of the shows,
they have a baby Trump puppet.
And he has a long, red
tie, and his hair is,
you know, going to the side.
And I've seen them where they
would introduce characters.
They would -- the devil
would be in the show
and they would rip
the devil's mask off,
and he was Darth Vader.
So, you could do with the
show whatever you want to do.
And that's part of the fun
with it, I think, you know?
But-- .
>> Michelle Stefano: In
England, before we get to Punch
and Judy here in the U.S.,
what were the main
functions of the tradition?
Where would you come across it?
How has that changed over time?
>> Mark Walker: Well, initially,
the show was seen
on the streets.
I mean that was it.
They appeared at
fairs and so forth.
And sometimes they weren't
necessarily the main attraction,
either.
They were used to bring
people into the fair.
That's how it began.
But most of the shows,
the earlier shows,
they were actually
intended for adults.
And if you look at some of
the prints and engravings,
you will see, most of the --
not to say their children
are not there, and not to say
that they weren't laughing,
but the performer would
often plate the adults
because they were the
ones that had money.
And the performer
had another person.
Usually it was a
two-person thing,
when they became glove puppets.
Sometimes it was
a family member.
If the performer was married,
hid wife would there,
the son, or whoever.
But if it was -- he
was working by himself.
There was always another person.
It could be a friend, or
somebody could pick up,
and it was called the
Bottler, B-O-T-T-L-E-R,
I think that's how
I spelled Bottler.
And that performer,
I mean, he was --
he assisted the entertainer.
His job was to help
draw a crowd.
And sometimes he would bang on
a drum and play some panpipes.
But actually, during the show,
his job was to take a bottle,
and go throughout the audience
and take up a collection.
That's basically what
he did, you know?
So, and again, it just evolved
and then, as I mentioned earlier
in the talks, but
you know, the --
his image became
the [inaudible],
as we moved into
the Victorian times.
And that's when they
cleaned up the shows.
A lot of the times,
the shows were --
they didn't have red and
white striped puppet theaters.
[Inaudible] called fit-ups,
F-I-T-U-P-S, fit-ups.
And a lot of times, they
used what was called ticking
which was a material
to cover mattresses.
A lot of times, it would be like
blue and white check material,
and that was what you
know, before they came
with the red and
white, you know?
And -- but, I'm not
rambling here [inaudible].
>> Michelle Stefano:
[Inaudible] yes.
This is so fascinating.
Well, tell us about the roots
of the tradition in the U.S.,
or when it migrated over
the Atlantic [inaudible].
>> Mark Walker: Yes, it was -- I
think Punch was here about 1742.
It was seen in -- I'm sorry.
It was seen in Philadelphia,
and I think there was
an advertisement for it.
They called it Punch and Joan.
And they advertised that
the figures were about two
or three feet high,
which would lead you
to believe they were
marionettes.
And it was.
It's called Punch and Joan.
You could see, it
had not evolved
into a true Punch
and Judy, as of yet.
And then in some of
the work that I did,
I said there was a book,
Maryland as a Palatinate,
they mention a Punch
and Judy in Annapolis,
and that was before the
American Revolutionary War.
And then I found a
Colonial newspaper.
The name escapes me.
But I know that Punch was
actually in Fell's Point,
Maryland, but that was also
done as a marionette show.
And that was -- like
somewhere like 1750, 1760.
So, it was here very early.
And they said that George
Washington in his records,
or journal, that
he bought a ticket
to see a Punch and Judy show.
So, it does go back.
And it was seen throughout
-- and there was a performer,
Albert Walker, he actually did
the show during the Civil War
at one of his -- I don't
have it on display,
but I have one of
his broadsides.
But he did the show
in the Civil War.
Interesting thing, his puppets,
they only had one
arm on each side.
They called it Economies
of Scale.
The audience only saw one side,
so he had one arm
facing [inaudible].
It was stupid, but
that's what he did.
But the shows played all around.
They were very big in
circuses and circus side shows.
That's where they
really picked up.
And a lot of times, with
the circus side shows,
they called it a 10-and-1-show
where you would go in
and pay money, and you
would see these 10 acts
for whatever it was, a dime,
and they would have a magician,
a fire eater, but one
of the performers was
always a Punch and Judy man.
And many of the guys were not --
well, they were full-time
entertainers, but not --
they did other things
other than Punch and Judy.
And if you were to study magic
history and Punch and Judy,
you see there is a correlation
between most of the Punch
and Judy men, not all, but
many have been magicians.
I can't explain that.
You know, it's just
one of the allied arts.
I guess that's the
best way to explain it.
And-- .
>> Michelle Stefano:
And you started
out as a magician as well.
>> Mark Walker: That's correct.
>> Michelle Stefano:
And you still are.
>> Mark Walker: Right,
that is correct.
And over in England
too, where they have --
and you didn't see it too much
here, but a lot of the Punch
and Judy men are magicians,
and also ventriloquists.
And there was two performers.
One, George Horn, he was a
magician and a ventriloquist.
He actually worked with two --
he actually had two figures.
Actually, had the one figure.
He sold me, and I kind of regret
selling it, but it was made
by Frank Marshall, which is a
very famous Chicago -- a carver.
And I sold it, and it was bought
-- I sold it for like $2,000.
I only paid $300 for it.
But it was sold to a collector.
And one time I was watching a
movie called "Rock the Cradle,"
and it starred Bill Murray, and
there was Oscar in that movie.
Bill Murray was using Oscar.
I almost fell out of my seat
when -- "There's Oscar."
And I remember I
had pictures of him
in my house, you
know what I mean?
But I just thought
that that was so funny.
But that, again, the idea of
a magician, ventriloquist,
Punch and Judy man,
not too much here,
but over in England,
you still see that.
They call it the Triple Threat,
where you could perform
all three of those skills.
You know, so.
>> Michelle Stefano: Well,
let's take it to Baltimore.
>> Mark Walker: Okay.
>> Michelle Stefano:
To the particular Punch
and Judy show tradition
that you are continuing.
It has a long legacy
in Baltimore.
The Horns.
>> Mark Walker: Right.
>> Michelle Stefano: Excuse me,
Horn's Punch and
Judy Show, 1897?
>> Mark Walker: Right.
There's a name -- a man
named James Edward Ross,
and he performed the show
at a place called Pat
Harris's Dime Museum.
And he was there for a
number of years, but his --
there was an amusement
park, no longer exists,
it was called Riverview,
and he was there every
Sunday performing.
Of course, it would be
during the summertime, okay.
And he was there for many years.
But he also performed -- he
actually performed at a lot
of the embassies in Washington
D.C. Performed at a lot of them.
And they performed at
Young's Million Dollar Pier
in Atlantic City.
He was there.
And they said that when
he performed on this pier,
they actually had during the
show, they also had seals.
A seal act.
And they would applaud
during the show.
And I thought that was so funny.
Seals applauding during
his Punch and Judy show.
But, yes but he was there for
many years and like I said,
Theodore Roosevelt saw his
show and absolutely loved it.
But there was a young gentleman,
George Horn, and he saw Rosella,
and he went to Riverview
all the time to see him,
and talk to him, and he
learned the show from him.
He learned the basics from
him, is what happened.
And Rosella actually taught one
or two other performers
how to do the show.
But what happens is,
is you learn the show,
it's almost like you also
-- it's like a soup starter.
You get it, here's the
basic thing, you take it,
and then you work
with it from there.
And it's really getting
a recipe.
You get a recipe and say,
"Oh, it's this," and say, "Oh,
but you know, it
would taste better
if I just added a little bit of
sage or I added this in there,
or [inaudible], or
Old Bay," you know?
You can throw Old Bay in there.
But it's -- and that's
how it works.
And I think that's the way it's
supposed to be meant to be.
You know, you start with
a basic thing, add to it,
and then make it better by
the time you're done with it.
Now, for me, what I did is I --
because I was really into magic
and magic history, and I
had written a couple magic
history books.
So, as I was getting into
Punch, I decided I was --
I saw what happened in the
magic collecting world,
where in the -- let's
see, my mom died in '87.
Somewhere around '87, '89,
the magic collecting
world went crazy.
Posters that you
could buy for 3, $400,
were now selling
for 3 or 4 thousand.
It just went crazy.
And I have some of those
now, but I had a --
I saw what happened
in the magic world,
and I thought, "You know what?
I don't hear a lot of talk
about Punch and Judy,"
and this was actually
pre-internet days, right?
Because I think that
came a little bit later.
And so, I just started to go
out and collect whatever I could
on Punch and Judy and books.
And as I read this stuff, I
-- read through their scripts
and say, "Now, that's
a good idea.
Maybe I could take this --
oh, that's a good joke."
Maybe I would take that.
And the one joke I have
in my show about the --
with the devil [inaudible],
"Well, if you're the devil,
let me shake your hand."
And, you know, "Why is that?"
"Because I'm married
to your sister."
Well, that was an old
joke that was given to me
by -- who's the guy's name?
Oh, it escapes me right now,
but he was a famous
-- it'll come to me.
Yes, the performer.
But he was from New York.
And his son told
me about that joke.
So, I thought, "What
a great joke.
I haven't heard that."
So, I added that to the show.
And it -- and some
of it's also me, too.
You know, I would hear things
or funny things would happen
and I would add it
into the show.
But I did keep some stuff
that was from Rosella.
That whole bit about the
devil, "You better not tell,"
and the monkey and all that.
That came from the
Rosella, George Horn show,
that I kept in there as
some of the features.
But some of the things,
like I said, I added it.
I saw some things done in
England, and I thought,
"Oh, that's pretty funny."
And I didn't copy it, per se.
I added you know,
my own bits to it.
And -- but by doing a lot of
research too, I was able to --
you know, there was
another performer.
He used that joke about,
his name's Punch Jr.
Jr. Jr. Jr. Get it,
he's part of the Punch line.
Which I thought was very funny.
And apparently, that
was used in a show,
and the performer was deceased,
and I had done research
on the performer, and I
thought, "What the heck?
That's a great line.
I'm going to use that."
And I don't think I'm the
only one that does that.
I think other performers, they
pick up a line here, a joke,
a gag or whatever, and you put
it in a show, and if it sticks
and it gets a good laugh,
you know, you leave it in.
And sometimes, it's
often been said you --
you have to give a
joke a while to --
you shouldn't disregard
a joke just
because the first audience
doesn't laugh at it.
Sometimes you just also have to
get the timing of it down too.
You know, it's just like
you say this, you wait two
or three seconds, and
then you say this.
And by doing that,
you know, you get it.
But again, you've
got to work it out.
Sometimes, you may get
a bad audience, too.
Never give up on a joke,
just right away, anyway.
But, anyway, that's
[inaudible] to it.
>> Michelle Stefano: Well,
going back to George Horn,
one of my favorite aspects of
the history of Horn's Punch
and Judy show, is how you
first came across him.
And in the 1960s?
>> Mark Walker: Right, right.
I was--
>> Michelle Stefano:
East Baltimore?
>> Mark Walker: Right,
so what happened,
it was the summer of '63.
And I went to -- I lived
around Patterson Park
in East Baltimore.
And I went to a Catholic
School, and we had the nuns.
But this one year, I happened to
have a lay teacher, [inaudible],
and she was a very nice lady.
And she said, toward the end of
the school year, "We're going
to have a summer picnic.
And we're going to you know,
I'm going to invite
everybody to it."
So, [inaudible], "Yes,
right, I'll never --
she's never going
to want to do that."
But then one time, during
the summer, some of the --
because I didn't live that
far from school and some
of the neighborhood
kids, "Hey, don't forget,
we're having this party."
So, I went over, and it was on a
Saturday, and I still remember,
we had hot dogs and sodas
and we played dodgeball,
and then we walked over.
It was around Baltimore
Street and Lakewood Avenue,
and it was George horn, and he
had his Punch and Judy cabinet
or fit-up there,
and he did the show.
And I just remember
-- I can't remember --
I actually cannot remember
too much about the show,
but I do remember
his puppet theater.
I thought, "Oh, that's
really neat.
That's neat."
Yes, but he did something
-- I sometimes do it,
and he's the only
one I ever saw do it.
He would bring out the
crocodile puppet at the very end
of the show, and he said, and
this is why I never forgot it,
he said, "If you let the
crocodile give you a very gentle
bite on the fingers, you'll have
good luck for a whole year."
And I thought, "Oh,
that's what I want.
You know, I want good luck
for the rest of the year."
So, I did that.
And I still do that sometimes,
if it's a smaller
crowd, manageable.
Or if something happens
and I have to stretch
for some particular reason,
you know, somebody's --
you know, Santa Clause is there.
"Can you hold off
and do something
for another you know,
15, 20 minutes?"
I'll do that, you know?
So, that's a great little thing.
But alright, so,
what was I saying?
>> Michelle Stefano: Well,
you first met him [inaudible].
>> Mark Walker: Oh,
yes, yes, yes.
>> Michelle Stefano: You
came across this show.
>> Mark Walker: So,
what happened was,
I remembered his name
and I think I discovered
the yellow page --
of course, they don't --
they're going out of style now,
the yellow page phone
directories.
And I saw his name.
It was listed under "Magicians."
And I said to him -- I
called him up, and I said,
"Do you have any
puppets for sale?"
And he, "Oh, I might
have a couple."
And I said, "Well, I'd like
to come over and visit you."
So, I talked to my parents and
they kind of humored me along
and you know, I just
kind of lost interest.
But there was a book out that
I got out of the library.
It was Punch and Judy
by Ed Emberly [phonetic],
I think is his name.
It was a children's book.
Had these wonderful
illustrations of Punch and Judy.
He also, I think he
was the illustrator.
And I checked that book out of
the library, I know, 30 times.
And it would go back in and
I would get it out again,
and go back -- and I used to --
as a kid, I used to dream
about doing this show.
But I was also getting
magic books out.
You know, [inaudible] a kid.
[Inaudible] got like a
thousand things going
on at the same time.
And so, what happened was,
I didn't think too much more
about Punch and Judy
till it was about 1985,
and I was at the house and my
mother said something to me.
She said, "Mark,
there's something coming
up on television about puppets."
And I had no idea what it was.
And I took a VCR tape.
What do you call them now?
I don't know what
they're called.
But I shoved it into the
recorder and I hit Record.
And it came up, and there
was a three-minute segment
on the weekend Saturday news.
And it was all about
Punch and Judy.
It was from England.
I actually still have that.
I kept that.
And it was John Stiles
who is probably one
of the world's most
famous Punch and Judy men.
He was a couple years ago,
he was awarded the MBE,
Member of the British
Empire by the Queen
for his work with
Punch and Judy.
There's a couple movies out,
102 Dalmatians, he
worked for Disney.
And [inaudible] Polar Express.
The scene was actually
cut, but if you look
in there, there is a scene.
He actually, Tom Hanks,
flew him to California.
He was there for like
a week doing that.
And he also did it with Roman
Polansky's Oliver Twist.
There's a little scene
of Punch and Judy.
So, he's a well-known
Punch and Judy man.
But when I saw this, this clip,
a lightbulb went off in my head.
And I said, "George Horn."
So, had it not been for
seeing this with John,
I would have never -- probably
would have never performed Punch
and Judy at all.
But it took two things.
It took George Horn and
it took this film clip
about John Stiles.
The two of them had to come in
and hit me at the right time,
and that's what did it.
And my niece had a birthday
coming up, and I was not married
at the time, and I
always did something fun
for their birthdays.
So, I called George
Horn up and told him.
I said, "Look, I saw your show
when I was a kid,
and ba, ba, ba."
So, I hired him,
and the kids were
in hysterics watching this show.
And I said, "What
a fantastic thing?"
But I looked at him, I mean, his
stage didn't look anywhere near
as good as this one, but
it was just such a fun act,
and I thought, "You know,
that's what I should be doing.
I really should."
So, his wife died probably
a couple months later,
and I called him up
and I'd be coming
over his house about
once a month.
And I would take
him out to dinner.
And I would just
go over his house.
I didn't want anything.
Just hanging there with him.
I didn't -- I asked him
about Punch and Judy,
and he also knew a lot about the
history of magic in Baltimore.
He had been around, what was it?
Since 1902, I think?
He'd been around for everything.
I mean, he knew Howard Thurston.
I mean Howard Thurston
came to his house once.
And -- that's a famous magician.
So, that's what happened.
I would come over there, and
then -- I said to him once,
I said, "Look, never
stop performing.
I think you have
a wonderful act.
You should always do it.
But, the day you decide
that you want to retire,
I'd be interested
in taking over."
And then one day, he called me
up, out of the blue, and said,
"Mark," he goes, "I think
I'm about ready to retire."
So, I think I bought
the show for about $300.
I said, you know,
"What do you want?"
He said, "Three hundred."
But I actually gave him an
extra $100 because I just --
and then, I worked with him,
and then he started to teach me
about the swazzle,
and then the show,
and we went over the script
and it was a lot of that.
So, I basically did his
show verbatim for a while,
because it's like -- I mean,
that was my soup starter.
I didn't know what to do.
You know? And the weird part
about doing the show first,
it took me about six months
to memorize the script,
but then you had to
get the timing of it
down in front of
a live audience.
And that's where it took
probably another year
or so for that to connect.
Because otherwise, you're just
doing this stuff, and you know,
people are -- they might
be laughing, or you've got
to figure out how to
get a laugh out of this.
And it's, again, it's
getting that timing down.
And you can only do that in
front of a live audience.
You can practice all you want,
but unless you're actually
there working in front
of a live audience,
you cannot get that.
So, we -- that took a year -- a
little bit better than a year.
But then even from there,
it was always learning.
Learning something else.
Trying something else.
And you know, [inaudible].
>> Michelle Stefano: And that's
a core aspect of the tradition,
that it's passed down and
usually there are apprentices
and obviously masters--
>> Mark Walker: Correct.
Yes.
>> Michelle Stefano: -like
George Horn was to you.
>> Mark Walker: Right,
that is correct.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
it's really interesting.
You know, you feel that it
took a year to really feel
that you were mastering, or you
had a good handle on the show?
>> Mark Walker: Well,
I would just say,
I was always a slow learner.
Probably took me a
little bit longer,
but I was having fun
too, and learning it.
And -- but at the same
time as I was doing it,
I was envisioning doing
something more than that.
And because I had some
puppets and his stage was beat
up -- kind of beat up.
So, it was then --
it was a case of --
I still have his
stage and his puppets.
But I wanted to rebuild that.
And then take it
up a few notches.
And then, I went over to
England, I think the year
after my son was born.
So, that would have been '96.
And I went over and had a
whole new set of puppets.
Not these, but some
other puppets.
And I had them made.
And I came back.
And then -- then I
started to really improve
and get with it and do stuff.
And again, you're never done.
You're never done.
You aren't, you know?
>> Michelle Stefano: Well,
that's what fascinates me,
this idea that you know, what
you learn, what are the skills
for instance, the puppet
making, and the timing sounds
like a core aspect of
what you need to practice.
>> Mark Walker: Right, right.
>> Michelle Stefano: And again,
receive from your master.
But let's talk about
the puppets.
>> Mark Walker: Sure.
>> Michelle Stefano:
So, who made yours
and what does it entail and--
>> Mark Walker: Right.
>> Michelle Stefano:
-what makes a good puppet?
>> Mark Walker: Well,
I have several sets.
I get all my sets
are made in England.
And I feel that they
make the best puppets
because they're not -- you
could be a good carver,
you could be an excellent
carver, but still,
not make a good puppet,
because it's --
I feel that the best
puppets come from people
that are actually
performing the show.
They understand all the
nuances with it, you know?
Like it's good to have a
puppet that's well-balanced.
Some of the heads, you can't
see it, but they'll drill holes
in there and use filler material
to make the head lighter.
And you -- a person -- a regular
carver, would not know that.
You know? And when I had a new
set of puppets made, I didn't --
my older sets were
made with glossy paint.
And I just thought -- I'd seen
that like sometimes under light
and it's that little
bit of glare.
So, I wanted semi-gloss
paint on there.
But again, these are these
little things you pick up
and then I also wanted
all my puppets lined.
That it wasn't just
one piece of fabric.
It was two sets in there.
And these little tricks of
the trade, you don't know,
but you finish your puppet show,
you turn the puppet inside out,
and it's two reasons why.
One is to dry the puppet
out in case you sweat
or whatever it is, but it's also
to protect the puppet
in transport.
So, it's covered by cloth.
Otherwise, the heads
are hitting one another.
So, it's these little things
you don't think about too much.
But I had my one set
that I'm using now,
was made my a wonderful carver.
The name Jeff Felix [phonetic].
And -- where's he live?
Oh, he lives right on
Wembley [phonetic].
Yes, somewhere in England.
And yes, he actually worked
for Henson and Disney,
and for Henson, I think
he did the -- what was it?
A couple Muppet movies.
Muppets Treasure Island,
and I forget what other
one he did for them.
But yes, but he -- he's
a wonderful carver.
Unfortunately, he had a
stroke about a year ago.
So, I'm not sure -- it's like
we used to exchange emails.
He can't even use email now.
So, I haven't talked
to him in a while.
And I kind of miss
talking to him, you know?
But it's -- I try to
communicate with this sister,
so she can get the
messages to him.
A couple of my puppets were made
by another person from England,
Brian Clarke [phonetic].
He actually made my
puppet stage for me.
He made the boxers.
And he -- but he's
a good carver.
But there are other -- some
of the performers that are
out there, they're still --
you know, they're
good carvers as well.
But again, they understand it.
And they can make the puppets.
So.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
how about the theater set,
which is what I would
call it, but I've learned
that it's called a fit-up.
>> Mark Walker: A
fit-up, that's correct.
Yes. There's various
different types.
They have some that
are very portable,
where it's like you just
set it up and, [inaudible],
it'll set up in a
matter of minutes.
It's probably -- I
think they're made
of a very lightweight aluminum,
and they could just set it
up right away, you know?
And I will say one
thing that has happened.
Years ago, most of the Punch
and Judy performers
worked standing up,
and the puppets were worked --
they would have their
hands up in the air.
So, imagine, you're standing
all the way up, and your --
the opening there, where the
puppets are being seen, I mean,
you're working like
this the entire show.
And I thought to myself,
"There's no way I
could do that."
But more and more,
that's being dropped,
and most of the guys
now are doing like I do,
and it's where you work with the
puppets in front of your face.
So, I stand up, and
they're right at this level,
and I can see through
the curtain.
So, you can see if
a puppet's drooping.
You know, you try to
keep some movement going.
But more and more, that's
what they're doing today.
And you can get you
know, the puppet stage
as elaborate as you want.
This was probably one
of the deluxe made.
And it was made by Brian Clarke.
And I went over there,
and I didn't know it,
but Brian was testing me.
I had the money.
I have to give him credit.
He said, I found out later,
even though I had the money,
he wasn't going to make this for
me, unless I used the swazzle,
because to him, that's
the only true Punch
and Judy man uses a
swazzle for Punch.
And he told Jeff, and I
found out later, he said,
"I'm not going to make
it if he [inaudible]."
So, he'd be willing to turn down
a couple thousand dollars just
on that principal alone.
But that just shows you
that's how serious he is.
Some of the performers
over there [inaudible].
>> Michelle Stefano: You've
been bringing up so many names
of performers from the past,
also those who are still working
or those who carve the puppets.
How do you all know each other?
What is the culture?
Do you have meetings or-- ?
>> Mark Walker: Well,
there's a group
out that's called the
Punch and Judy Fellowship.
And even that, that took me
years to track that down.
Of course, that was before
the internet, you know?
It's -- I had heard about it,
and somebody told me about it.
And then I had to
write to somebody.
They sent me the address.
Of course, you go online
today, everything's online.
I said, there are no
secrets in the world.
But that is -- they have a
publication called The Swazzle.
But it's for the Punch
and Judy Fellowship.
And I actually --
I tracked down --
I went after with a vengeance, I
got every issue of The Swazzle,
dating back to like
the early 70s.
And I have a complete
file of that.
And -- it was a complete file.
I was really getting
into the periodicals.
So, I got the animations.
I think I have one
of the largest Punch periodical
collection in the world,
because I've seen some
of the other performers.
I'm not saying I have the
biggest book collection,
but as far as the
periodicals are concerned.
There was another publication.
It was called The
Magical Digest.
And it was owned by a guy
named Oscar Oswald [phonetic],
in England.
And there were very few sets.
And I know that I have
a complete set of that.
And actually, got a set from
our friend John Stiles, too.
You know, just a gift to him,
because I'm really
good friends with him.
But that's how the
-- more or less,
it's communicating that way.
And they have their puppet
festivals over in England.
They have a big May
Day Festival.
They used to have
one in fall, but --
I think I was over
there -- I can't recall.
Was it a May Day Festival
or the fall of the year?
But I went over there, and you
just hang with all the guys.
I mean, they're very accepting.
I mean, they kind of
think, "Oh, this guy came
from America," you know?
And but there's guys that would
travel from Italy, you know,
all around, and so forth.
So, I've gotten to
know a lot of them.
I've been to their houses too,
a couple -- more than once.
And but you know, you
talk shop and stuff.
But then after a while, they
just become your friends.
So, you don't even have
to talk about puppets.
Just, "Hey, what are you doing?"
You know, "Ba, ba,
ba," so forth.
But, you know.
>> Michelle Stefano:
So, it sounds like Punch
and Judy's thriving in the U.K.
>> Mark Walker: In
the U.K., yes.
>> Michelle Stefano: How is
it doing here in the U.S.?
>> Mark Walker: Just okay.
Part of the reason is,
is the man isn't there.
And I also think it's
a marketing problem.
And I've often had that -- I've
known that for a long time.
Most -- if you say
Punch and Judy,
you'll often hear two things.
One, "What is that?"
Or two, "Oh, that's a
violent puppet show."
That's usually what you hear.
And so, it's very
hard to overcome that.
I mean, I've figured out some
ways how to get around it,
but -- and market myself,
but it's also a little bit
with political correctness
as well.
I know a performer,
Fred Greenspan [phonetic],
real nice guy.
He lives in Palm
Beach, and I was --
I stopped down to
see him in January.
And we were talking.
And he left New York
because of --
well, there was a variety
of reasons, but he just said
where he could no longer bring
out a slapstick in the show.
And all of a sudden, they
didn't want to see, like a devil
on the show, or the crocodile.
And it was -- it's
like after a while,
it was like, "Give me a break."
But like for me, I
won't bend on that.
You know? It's going to
have those characters.
And I will say this, I've
learned some lessons.
I've learned Punch and
Judy is best not performed
at daycare centers,
and children museums,
because what happens is you
run into helicopter parents,
and teacher -- educators.
And it's like, "Oh, no.
Joey can't fall down.
Oh, no, no, don't fall down."
You know? And it's just that
where somebody does fall down,
[inaudible], "Hey, maybe
I won't run next time."
You know? That type of thing.
But it's -- by staying
away from those two venues,
I've had no complaints.
None, at Festival.
Alright, I did have --
alright, let me just say this.
Once in a blue, blue moon.
Once every five or six years.
Once I was doing a --
performing a Christmas show
and the children were
laughing their heads off.
And this lady came
up to me in the back
and she's pulling on my leg.
Now, I'm doing a show and
I've got a microphone on.
And she goes, "Mr.
Horn, Mr. Horn."
And it's -- you know, so you've
got these puppets up in action.
"Yes, yes?"
"You're scaring the kids."
I'm like, "What?
What are you talking about?
They're out there
laughing their heads off."
So, at the end of the
show, the -- what was it?
The guy who hired me, I was
talking with him and he said,
"What did they say to you?"
And I said, "Well, they said
I was scaring the kids."
And he said, "Scaring the kids?"
He goes, "What is
she talking about?"
And I mentioned something to
her about the Three Stooges,
and she said, "Oh, I
hate the Three Stooges."
And I said that to him,
and he goes, "What?
She doesn't like
the Three Stooges."
He says, "I'm never going to
let that idiot in here again."
So, I mean, there's the
kind of crazy stuff.
But I have to say, that
rarely, rarely ever happens.
I hear no complaints
at birthday party.
None. None.
I perform in Fells
Point on a street.
Of course, I never
hear anything there.
Festivals, I never
hear any complaints.
And I've performed in a lot
of, you know, some museums,
upscale museums, art
museums, and so forth,
and I don't get any
complaints about it.
But it's -- I think
when you, again,
when there's very young
children, and you know,
parents that hover over
their children and so forth,
and educators like that, I think
sometimes you run into issues.
So, I just try to avoid
those issues, that's all.
So, you know.
>> Michelle Stefano: I know it's
a Baltimore based tradition,
this particular Horn show,
but is there a connection
to Fell's Point,
the neighborhood
on the harbor in the city?
>> Mark Walker: Well, like I
said, there was a show there.
It was -- and I've --
I only found this out like
about a year ago, and the fact
that there was a Punch show
down there in the 1700s.
So, when I first started out,
I thought, because I liked
that area, I thought, "You
know, I'm going to go down here.
It's -- go down at
Christmas time."
And I don't know what
possessed me to do this,
because I wasn't
connected with anybody.
But I went and set up
on a street corner.
They had a parade
of lighted boats,
and I set up and did my show.
I got a big reaction.
So, then I became
known down there and --
people, and then I got booked
for the Fell's Point
Fun Festival.
So, this went on and on and on.
And then, probably about
five years ago, I thought,
"I'm either going to take
this show up a few notches,
or I'm going to maybe
stop performing
down there altogether."
So, I sent the letter out to
a lot of people, what was it?
Business leaders, people that
owned properties and so forth
and said, "Look,
this is the dream.
I want to come down here,
and perform my show.
And the whole idea is to have
something for the children,
and so forth, and you know,
I'm willing to be, you know,
as far as put a banner up saying
my show is sponsored by you."
So, I sent it out to
all these individuals.
But -- and there was
this one gentleman,
his name was Dominic
Echenstein [phonetic].
He's from Switzerland.
And he had a -- there
was a hotel,
the Admiral Fell Inn [phonetic],
and what happened was, is I --
he asked me to do
some shows, and he --
then he said, he
was going to pay me.
And I said, "No,
forget about it."
And again, I thought
he just worked there.
I had no idea he owned the
hotel and he was very wealthy.
So, years later when I
sent these letters out,
I sent one to him, and
Dominic called me up and said
that he would like
to sponsor my show.
So, that's what happened.
He sent me to England for
two weeks, and I was able
to get the show of my dreams
built, and I perform now
at Fells Point about two
or three times a month.
And I perform for free.
And I actually have things that
I -- have a banner that says,
"Sponsored by Dominic
Echenstein,
the Admiral Fell
Inn," and I give
out these little finger
puppets that has his name
on it, and the hotel's name.
So, it's a very good
will gesture.
And actually, they give me free
valet parking, which is great.
Oh, what's not to like?
I pull up.
They take my car.
They park it.
And they deliver it
right to me at the end.
I mean, this is like a
-- you know, it's like,
what a great gig
this is, you know?
So, I'm there for -- I
think I've just completed my
first year.
I've got about another
five to go.
So, but I like doing
it, and they like it.
So, it's -- that's my connection
with Fells Point, you know?
>> Michelle Stefano: One
of my favorite questions
to ask masters in any tradition
really, is why do they do it?
Why do you -- I mean, just from
listening to you all day today,
it's obvious you have a lot
of passion for not only magic,
but obviously Punch and Judy
shows as well, and the puppetry
and all the knowledge and
skills [inaudible] behind it.
What is it?
>> Mark Walker: I think the
key thing for me is that,
and you look around and see
something that was around
and then it no longer exists.
I walk around some
shopping districts
that -- when I was a child.
And it looked like
a bomb went off.
I mean, these stores
no longer exist.
A lot of things that I --
certain stores, people --
neighborhood characters,
they're gone.
And but when I saw this show,
I just -- I thought to myself,
"If I walk away from that,
that show's gone forever."
And you know, "I
can't save the world,
but I could save one thing."
And that's, I think,
what caused it.
The other thing too is that,
well, it's somewhere --
it was in the early 80's, that
movie came out, Home Alone.
And I remember, you
couldn't get tickets to get
into the movie theater.
I had two nieces, and
I took them in there.
And unless you were there,
you wouldn't understand it.
I heard children laugh like I'd
never heard them laugh before.
And the reason for it,
it was slapstick comedy.
And I didn't know about Punch
and Judy at that point, see?
So, when -- and I always
said, "That's the kind
of laughs I really want
to get in my show."
It's one thing to get a
couple laughs, but I really --
I thought, that true
laughter here,
little kids just
spontaneous laughter,
that's what I was aiming for.
And when I saw George
Horn's show years later,
and I heard that,
I said, "That's it.
That's it."
So, it was a combination of
those two things, you know?
Plus, I'm kind of
like a nostalgic guy.
I am. You know, I'll
admit that, you know?
>> Michelle Stefano:
That's surprising.
So, who's apprenticing to you?
How is it going to
be carried on?
>> Mark Walker: I
don't necessarily know.
Now, two things have happened.
One is, years ago,
I was approached
by Maryland Traditions.
And my son, this is -- to me,
this is an interesting story.
So, somewhere -- well,
he was born in '95.
My son has actually seen my show
-- my son, he'll be 23, but --
I would say my son has seen the
show several thousand times,
because he would go with
me to every show he could,
except birthday parties.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Wait, thousands?
>> Mark Walker: Several
thousand [inaudible].
>> Michelle Stefano: What?
>> Mark Walker: And I actually
have it on video somewhere,
but when he was about 5 or
6, I brought the show back
and I just put -- I put it
there, without the top on.
And he stood up on a chair and
did my whole show, you know,
for 15 minutes, from
start to end.
And he was saying some stuff --
I had a joke there about Viagra.
He had no idea what
I was talking about.
But I mean, it was a
joke and he did that.
And every once in a while, he
would say, "Dad, what's next?"
And I would give him the line,
and then he'd, [inaudible].
And he would do that.
My wife and myself, we
were just besides our self
that he knew the show.
So, when Maryland Traditions
approached me, I just said,
"You know, my son, you
know, I'd be willing
to teach the show to him."
So, that's what happened.
And we got this award,
and actually,
that's how I went to England.
I took him and my wife, and
we went to England and we went
to a Punch and Judy festival,
but he could do the
show for a while.
But his interest has kind
of swayed a little bit.
I mean, he's a chef now and --
but he does do standup comedy.
I think I rubbed off to him
in some respects, you know?
I mean, I would like
for him to do it,
but I don't think you
should force anybody.
It's got to come from within.
But I have actually -- I have --
I'm not releasing it any time
soon, but I've written something
about Punch and Judy, the
American Punch and Judy Show,
where I've taken --
I've recorded all of it,
as far as like what you should
do, you know, if you're working,
you know, in this
situation, and so forth.
So, one day, that'll
go to somebody.
Maybe I'll teach a
course in Punch and Judy.
I don't know.
But that's further
down the road.
You know? But I've taken
those steps to do that.
So, it's hopefully all
is not lost, you know?
So, I would hate to --
I wish somebody would
have given me this,
and that would have been
what I started with.
But a lot of it I had
to learn on the fly.
Yes. So.
>> Michelle Stefano: I
guess I'm dying to ask,
"How racy can your show get?"
>> Mark Walker: Well,
they have -- racy.
I mean, you could do with it
-- I mean, I have some jokes --
I actually hold back some jokes.
I'm not going to say them here.
And I mean, I don't think
they're necessarily bad.
I mean, there are some that
I've used, and again, I don't --
they're suggestive,
innuendos, I would say.
And but I've had a couple
people, I mean just,
almost spit their water out
when they would hear lines,
but you know, I try to
be a little bit careful.
They have these things
-- I don't go to them,
but they're called Puppet Slams.
And they're actually meant
for an all adult audience,
where you will come and put
on a puppet show, for adults,
and you could use
adult material.
And I've been asked to do that,
but I've just -- I don't know.
I just -- I'm not really a
-- I like Punch and Judy --
or let me just say this.
I love the Muppets,
but I would never want
to do that type of show.
I like marionettes.
I would never want
to do that show.
It's just something about Punch
and Judy, that just got to me.
And I have no desire
to do any other kind
of puppet show, but
Punch and Judy.
I'll admit, it's -- you know,
it's it for me, you know?
So.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Just for later,
when we get some good
footage of all your items,
I'd just like to ask you
about your collection.
How you've amassed it and what--
>> Mark Walker: Sure.
>> Michelle Stefano: -what
has driven it and what --
maybe some items you have in it
that you could talk about now,
and then we'll look
at in a little bit.
>> Mark Walker: Sure, yes.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Well, I mean,
some of the things you
know, a lot of the items --
well, thank goodness
for eBay, you know?
That's where I found
some things.
Other things, I -- this one item
over there, it's a French print.
It was the goofiest story.
I was with my son in
Harford County, Maryland.
We went to an antique mall
-- a mall with antiques.
And I said to him,
"Wouldn't it be funny
if I found something
with Punch and Judy?"
And the next thing I
know, I found this print.
Then it had some
kind of stain on it.
So, I went to a professional
restorer,
called Garro [phonetic].
And all the magicians use Garro.
And I said, "I want
to put it on linen,
but I want you to clean it up."
And when they did, all
the color came off of it.
I almost died.
I thought, I mean that's --
"I didn't want the
color to come out.
I just wanted you
to clean it up."
That took me eight
years to find this.
And I just determined
to get this,
and I went after it
with a vengeance.
And I was at a magic
collectors' meeting,
and I knew it was from France.
And I was at this meeting, and
there was this guy from France,
and I said -- he had
broken English and I talked
with him, and he had it.
But he didn't want to sell it.
So, we went back and forth,
back and forth, and finally,
I think in January or
something, he said,
he'd be willing to sell it.
My wife's not here, is she?
Okay. But it was a lot of money.
I was determined to get
it, and he sold it to me,
so I got it back again.
But -- just don't tell my wife.
Anyway, that's the story
with that one, yes.
So, I found that one.
Other ones I found, you
know, it's here and there.
It's hit and miss.
You know, one of the
things, a Victorian scene,
I actually bought that while I
was in London on my honeymoon.
Cecil Court, there was a
place there, like a Pleasures
and Past Times, or
something like that.
But I bought that one there.
Other ones I picked up on eBay.
A guy named Jonathan Reynolds
who had a place called Dramatis
Persona [phonetic], and he dealt
in rare books -- all dealt
with the theater and so forth.
I don't know if Jonathan's
still around, but that one there
from Portugal, from
1828 with the Queen,
Queen of Portugal,
I got that from him.
I think I only paid 300 for it,
but I bet that thing's worth
about a thousand dollars today.
I've never seen another one.
I've showed it to friends over
in England, and they say, "Wow.
What a nice piece," you know?
But you know, it's like --
again, you pick them up here,
you pick them up there, and
all my walls on my house,
I have them all displayed.
>> Michelle Stefano: So,
you kind of have like a --
a bit of a museum at home?
>> Mark Walker: I mean,
it's sort of like that, yes.
But there's certain rooms my
wife won't get me go into.
She kicked me out
of the powder room.
I'm no longer in that one.
I mean, when you come into
the house, it's all there.
You know? But it's --
she won't let me go --
I said, nothing in the kitchen,
nothing in the powder room,
and then there's like a family
room there, nothing in there.
But I have the parlor
and the dining room
and so forth, you know?
Plus, I actually
have lot of stuff.
I just don't have it
displayed, because it's --
and I have some filing cabinets.
You know, I've got a lot of
Punch and Judy in there, too.
So, a lot of it's just
packed away, you know?
But it's -- anyway.
>> Michelle Stefano: Why
are you collecting now?
This is my last question.
Just in general.
What's the need?
>> Mark Walker: I don't
think there's a need.
I mean, you know, I've written
a lot of articles about Punch
and Judy, and I've
written, you know,
in the Swazzle publication.
I wrote that whole story
about George [inaudible],
was such a huge hit with them.
You could -- you will find
nothing written about that man.
Nothing. But I found his -- was
it great nephew, or somebody?
Or a relative.
And that's how I was
able to trace this.
And that -- they still
talk about this story,
because he was considered
to be a god over in --
probably one of the best
Punch and Judy men in America.
And -- but they still talk
about him today over in England.
So, it's like finding this
stuff and writing these stories,
and yes, it's like putting
puzzles together, you know?
You get a little
bit of information,
you do a little research.
There's another guy, his
name's Dagmar [phonetic],
and there is a film clip, it was
an opera, "Naughty Marietta,"
I think is the name of it.
But there's a little
scene in there,
of him doing a Punch
and Judy show.
But it's probably only
about two minutes long.
But I've been doing
some research on him.
So, I'll probably
write an article
in the Swazzle about him.
So, I mean, some of it's just
to write articles or stuff.
So, I mean, it's just collecting
it and preserving it, saving it.
You know? But yes,
today, I don't know
if I would do it all over again.
But I have no regrets.
None whatsoever, you know?
So, I mean, cataloging
it and so forth,
so my wife knows what all
the stuff is, you know?
So, it's -- so she
doesn't say, "Oh look,
you know, a bunch of letters."
Throw them out.
It's like, "God, do you
know what's in there?"
You know, it's all these
letters written by this guy.
I mean, I've had letters
-- I actually have a --
it wasn't Punch and Judy,
but I've got a postcard
from John Waters [phonetic].
He's talking about
one of my books
and saying how much he liked it,
and you know, a couple letters
from Teller, of Penn and Teller,
how much of a fan he was of one
of my books, and so forth.
And I wanted to keep
all that together,
so my wife doesn't
say, "Oh, look at this.
Old correspondence," and
just throw it out, you know?"
So, yes, I mean it's
-- you know?
>> Michelle Stefano: So,
anything you feel I should have
asked you or you'd like to add?
>> Mark Walker: Do
you have time?
You guys got time, or what?
We running out of time?
>> Could we just ask
a quick question--
>> Mark Walker: Sure.
>> -as a lay person?
>> Michelle Stefano: Yes.
>> And you speak
directly what I ask?
Can you just describe
what a swazzle is?
>> Mark Walker: Yes.
So, a swazzle.
It's about the size
of a postage stamp.
But just imagine two of them.
Okay? And they're made of metal.
They used to be made out of
aluminum, until they found
out you're not supposed
to use that.
So, the good ones are
actually made out of silver.
So, I actually had mine made
over in England from
a silversmith.
And they're curved.
And what happens is, is you use
this -- it has to be cotton.
It's a cotton twill tape,
and you run it through there,
around this other piece.
You wrap it around.
And then you tie a piece
of thread around it.
And then you dip it in water,
and then put it in your mouth,
and as you blow through
it, it makes this sound.
It's like a reed.
You know what a reed is, right?
And you speak, and you
speak through that,
and that's what gives you
Mr. Punch's voice, you know?
But they'll drive you
crazy, the swazzles,
because sometimes it's --
you'll have to make them three,
four, five, six times.
You try it.
It doesn't -- they say the good
ones is that when you blow,
where you can get the right tone
from the front and the back.
And if you can get that,
that's a good sound.
But and then the other
thing is you have to,
usually when you're making
it, you're actually dipping
that twill tape, it's a --
like a herringbone, cotton,
twill tape or something.
But you're going to have
to dip it in hot water.
So, you -- and that's --
and then after it
shrinks a little bit,
that's when you use it
to make your swazzle.
But that's what gives
you Mr. Punch's voice.
Yes.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
how long do they last?
>> Mark Walker: A good while.
A good while, you know?
You know, I should actually
have spares with me.
You know, they say that you
should have two or three spares.
I don't. And I feel
ashamed, because --
I haven't swallowed one yet,
and a lot of people have.
And they actually say you're not
a good Punch and Judy performer
until you swallow one.
But I'm kind of glad that --
I hope I go throughout my life
without swallowing one
of those, you know?
We won't get into what you have
to do afterwards, but yes, yes.
That's about it with that.
I have some stories if
you want [inaudible]?
>> Michelle Stefano: I
want to hear stories, yes.
>> Mark Walker: Alright, okay.
Some stories.
I had a call once to do a
Punch and Judy show for a --
this guy called me up and
said, "Hey, I want you to do --
it's a birthday party."
And I said, "Okay."
And I said -- he says, "My
son, though has a handicap."
He didn't say what it
was, and I didn't ask him.
And I went to his house, and he
was -- they were very wealthy.
He was a doctor.
And his son, I guess it's
okay to say it here, right?
His son had no ears.
And that was his thing.
But his father made for him,
some kind of device that went
over his head, like a
headset, so his son could hear.
And during the show,
his son was acting up.
And afterwards, the father said,
"I have never seen my son get
so excited about a
show in all my life."
You know? And it kind of touched
me when he did that, you know?
And that was one
experience that I had.
And another time, some guy
said, "I have this event.
We're celebrating our
100th anniversary.
I'd like for you to
come out to perform."
And I said, "Sure."
I said, "Well, what
kind of event is it?"
And he goes, "Well,
we're a funeral parlor,
and we're celebrating
our 100th anniversary."
So, okay, okay.
So, it was in the fall of
the year, and I was coming
to the event, and I said,
"Oh, where will I perform?"
He goes, "Oh, outside."
I said, "Okay."
So, I was coming to the event,
and it was pouring down rain.
And I'm thinking, "Oh, he's
going to cancel for sure."
So, I get there,
and I said, "Well,
I guess you're going to cancel?"
And he goes, "No, no, no.
We're going to move it indoors."
So, I went in, and that's
where I was performing it,
in one of the viewing rooms,
my Punch and Judy show.
And for the longest time, I
didn't want to ask the guy,
like you know, where's
all the bodies, you know?
But because -- I
found out later,
because it was their
100th anniversary,
they had closed the
shop down for a week,
so they could repaint
and put you know,
new carpet in and so forth.
But, I always thought
that was a good one.
I had one booking that
I did for many years.
I did it for about
five or six years.
I was actually hired
by a group of lawyers.
And I won't tell you the name of
the program, but I would perform
for very, very good
money, three shows a year.
And then what would
happen is, the people --
the children would come
in and watch my show,
and then they would
leave the room,
and they would be interviewed.
And the whole purpose
was, they were being --
they were talking to
lawyers, people studying law.
And it was to test their
memories, to see how much
that they could remember.
And it was basically to check,
I guess for, if they were --
like child abuse or something.
And like how good
was their memory?
And the people interviewing
me, had not seen the show.
They were asking them, and
then they're saying, "Oh,
this crocodile came in.
There was this monkey."
But that was the whole idea.
They were -- they talked
about the magic show,
but the Punch and Judy as well.
But, I really thought that
was a pretty good one.
And another time, a couple
years back, it was Captain --
what was it, Captain
John Smith, was that it?
But they had a big celebration.
What was it, 300
years, 350 years?
And while I was there, they
put me at this spot, and said,
"This is where I
want you to perform."
And what happened was,
I was next to a gallows.
And they would bring a guy
up, and hang this person.
Of course, he had a
brace on and everything,
but they would bring him up on
the thing, put him up there,
pull the thing, and the guy
would just drop and hang.
And then they would say,
"And now we're going
to have our children's
entertainment."
So, I followed that.
And I just thought that that --
how bizarre is that, you know?
And it's like, how
do you follow that?
You know? But that
was just another one
of those crazy things, you know?
But I've had all kind of like,
crazy things like that happen.
And there were fun things too.
And I actually think
that's another reason why I
like to perform.
I get to meet people,
like you guys.
And it's, go places I
would never go otherwise.
And anyway, that's part
of the fun business of it.
You know, so.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Well, thank you so much.
>> Mark Walker: Thank you.
>> Michelle Stefano: That
was absolutely wonderful.
>> Mark Walker: Well, thank you.
So.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at Loc.gov.